it isn't enough to highlight liberal
bias among social media giants there
needs to be a way to fight back an
alternative I think it's easy to lose
track of all actions taken by these
companies but here's an incomplete list
of recent punitive steps taken
personalities Alex Jones Milo innopolis
and Laura Loomer have been permanently
banned by Twitter Candice Owens was
suspended by Facebook for seven days for
saying white supremacy was not as big a
threat to America as fatherlessness
Michelle Malkin was censored by Facebook
for opposing the censorship of some of
those I just mentioned and perhaps most
jarring dance Gavino Trump's social
media director he was temporarily banned
by Facebook in April after his posts
were flagged by quote an algorithm now
one company is stepping into the breach
however to solve this parlor is a
Twitter like platform that was launched
last year it's already attracted a
number of powerful people including
Senator Mike Lee and Trump campaign
manager Brad Parr scale
my next guest hopes that's just the
beginning here now is CEO of parlor
John mates John is this really going to
be a Twitter alternative that
conservatives have been seeking I don't
really like the idea being an
alternative life form
I think that I think that it should be
more of the platform that social media
should have been when it was originated
I mean the reality is they are more Act
they're acting more like publications
rather than a community forum and that's
generally that's what should be created
as a community forum for people to
discuss politics whatever they'd like so
no censoring if someone says something
inciting violence will you leave it up
well see that that's actually against
the law so anything that we kind of get
involved with has to have some kind of
constitutional violation some kind of
Supreme Court premise something that
says hey you know that's really not all
right there has to be a premise for it
though we really don't want to get into
the business of kind of determining what
is and is not allowed to be discussed
now what's your platform for making
money here is
you know using and I look through your
privacy statement I always do that
believe it or not I started looking
through all these comes they gather
information cookies you can ask for your
contacts to be shared photos most of
that's boilerplate I mean to be honest I
know I read the boilerplate I'm a lawyer
the boilerplate is actually really
important most people don't read it and
that's why they get in trouble but how
do you make money in this you make money
by partnerships and so forth with the
information you gather well right now
we're not gonna mean no we're never
going to be selling any information so
there's no that that's not really in our
business model but we want to do is kind
of recreate what marketing should have
been in a way that we're not targeting
people not using their information to
find them rather we kind of want to
provide them with with more of an
old-school approach to advertising and
that's what will eventually be doing as
well as influencer marketing because
that's really important right now that
influencers can convey the message
better than than individuals or page as
a whole right so if someone who has a
big media following just like they have
an Instagram will you make money on
Instagram or YouTube you can make money
maybe is it parlor or parlay I'm hearing
two different parlor it used to be no
one's gonna say that by the way I'm
gonna change you came for you just call
it parlor it's actually it's a double
meaning of going to a parlor a beauty
parlor or a salon a parlor so I just say
that is exactly what happened good I
think that's smart but we are looking
forward to seeing where this goes I know
Michelle Malkin I think and others are
fascinating I just might sign up later
in the night so that would be great I
mean we've got a lot of people that are
that are being censored and a lot of
people that just want to join a
community where they can actually
discuss without worrying about what's
going to freedom them your arm freedom
on a new platform called parlor I
appreciate it thanks so much